[Musique]
après les radars classiques que vous
connaissez ou encore les radars
tourelles pour voir si vous êtes
attachés ou non place aux radars méduses
il est équipé d'une caméra et de quatre
micros qui permette de verbaliser les
véhicules trop bruyant ce radar méduse
peut aussi évaluer la direction de
provenance du bruit on a pris la
décision de mettre un petit capteur
photo dans le système dont le centre
optique est confondu avec le centre
acoustique du système ce qui permet en
gros 2 en prenant une photo de projeter
dans l'image les directions nous convier
le bruit donc d'avoir la trajectoire
réel ce radar méduse est installé sur la
route départementale 91 dans la vallée
de chevreuse fameuse route des dix sept
tournant qui se veut le terrain de jeu
des motards une route pourtant à limitée
à 50 km heure il suffit de venir se
promener le samedi ou le dimanche dans
la vallée de chevreuse pendant les mois
d'été pour s'apercevoir des nuisances
considérable que subissent les riverains
et les habitants
l'installation de ce radar divise les
motards certains comprennent alors que
d'autres sont un peu sceptiques mais si
on a la vallée de chevreuse
il ya des centaines de motards qui sont
là tous les jours et je peux comprendre
que pour les gens qui habitent juste en
bas de la vallée se doit pas être super
sympa d'entendre les rupteurs tous les
jours va par exemple j'ai acheté une
moto avec des peaux qui ont été changés
normalement ils sont censés être
homologué mais c'est vrai qu'il fait
quand même assez de bruit et je me
demande si moi je peux passer à une
allure on va dire respectable sans
prendre de but
le système de verbalisation est encore à
l'étude ce radar méduse est en
expérimentation pendant un an et demi